c'est sa fille Claude qui a choisi le
modèle et la couleur de sa voiture et
aussi la cassette de Michel Berger qu'on
ne peut pas changer elle est coincée le
weekend je suis toujours au volant de ma
voiture je vais à la messe à
saint-gervervetis au volant de ma
voiture et je vais voir des membres de
ma famille au volant de ma voiture et
quelquefois le soir je crois qu'il ne
faut jamais lâcher son volant il faut
garder son
indépendance vivere comme tout le monde
vivre la vie du citoyen de tous les
jours sinon je suis persuadé qu'on perd
pied très vite mais quand bloqué dans un
bouchon place de la Concorde la
citoyenne Bernadette Chirac est salué et
reconnu ça lui fait vraiment plaisir
merci les gens vous
reconnaissent beaucoup mais c'est
sympathique Bernadette Chirac va
s'acheter des livres erreur de parcours
problèmes de stationnement travaux tous
les énervements habituels d'une
automobiliste ordinaire tu m'embêtes
hein je je vais pas quand même
regardez-moi ça c'est imbécile